they missed key evidence how is that
even possible this is the highest
profile criminal case that we've had in
this country
probably since o.j simpson george
floyd's dna in the back of the squad
card and they somehow missed that
so let's begin with the chief question
here what was the cause of death so in
order to convict shove and murder you
first have to show causation
that it was his actions that led to
floyd's death and it can't just be but
for causation
okay there's two types of causation
there's causation in fact and there's
but for causation
but for causation means there's a chain
of events leading to an outcome
but for any link in that chain
the outcome would not happen so for
example if george floyd doesn't get out
of bed in the morning
he doesn't die that day maybe right so
that is a but for causation fact
if if the person in front of him at the
stoplight had sped through a yellow
maybe he's not there at that particular
time and place is that person
responsible for his death no because
there's a difference between but four
causation and then causation in fact
if there are many intervening factors in
a particular case that goes to the
question
of causation in fact so the defense is
arguing
i think on fairly strong terms here that
george floyd's massive
drug use contributed to his death and
that if you have to
allocate where the causation lies it
lies much more with
with floyd's drug use than it lies with
chalvin using
this suppression hold okay this is the
subject of controversy but that's the
entire point
you don't have to believe that the
defense is 100 correct to acknowledge
that reasonable doubt exists because
again the standard in criminal law
is not who do i think is right but can
you prove beyond a reasonable death it's
a very high standard in criminal law
beyond a reasonable doubt that chalvin
killed floyd
not floyd's pre-existing heart condition
and massive drug use
okay so how extensive was floyd's drug
use and people are saying this is
slandering floyd it's not slandering
floyd it goes to the heart of the case
this is one of the ways that the media
bias the case they say you're not even
allowed to talk
about floyd's behavior in the lead-up to
the actual tape
you're not allowed to talk about floyd's
medical status well if you're not
allowed to talk about that stuff then we
should
be honest to god should not have defense
in this country we should not have legal
defenses in this country if you can't
talk about the factors leading to the
guy's death
so this is not an argument about floyd's
character because
frankly his character doesn't matter
here the only thing that matters here
is the causation that's the only thing
that matters
that's why i don't find it particularly
relevant what his criminal history was
he had a bad criminal history i don't
think it's very relevant to this case
what his criminal history was
other than police running his his name
for example or his id
and recognizing that maybe in the past
he'd had run-ins with cops and so you
have to be
extremely careful with him right the
question is always what is the relevance
of the evidence to this particular case
and so
the the relevance here is that george
floyd was a serious drug addict
not only was he a serious drug addict
he's a serious drug addict who had
overdosed in the recent past
courtney ross is floyd's girlfriend and
she testified on the stand
that just a few months ago he actually
overdosed and they tried to bring him to
the er
he wasn't feeling good his stomach
really hurt he was doubled over in pain
um just wasn't feeling well and he said
he had to go to the hospital
so i took him straight to the hospital
you later learned that that was uh
due to an overdose yes
okay well he'd already overdosed in the
past few months
not only did he already overdose in the
past few months as we will see he was
high
at the time that he was arrested quite
high right by the by the toxicology
report
very very high and not only that his
drug dealer was in the car with him
in all likelihood it turns out that the
man in the car
with george floyd the day he died
refuses to testify now
his testimony might be relevant you
think the reason that he's refusing to
testify is because
he was his drug dealer the man's name is
maurice hall
he's currently in jail he appeared via
zoom at a court hearing on tuesday
morning in which his attorney argued he
has no immunity from prosecution that
stems from testimony about his and
floyd's behavior while seated in a
mercedes-benz suv shortly before the
police arrived on may 25th
and arrested floyd hey now here's the
weird part
here's the weird part normally it is the
prosecution
that can offer immunity not normally
it's the only way this works the
prosecution
goes to somebody whose testimony they
want and they offer him immunity
in exchange for his testimony the
prosecution doesn't want morty's hall to
testify
isn't that somewhat suspicious the man
sitting next to george floyd
in the car his drug dealer they don't
want him to testify
and the defense can't compel his
testimony because he can use the fifth
why is he claiming the fifth
why is he saying that he might
incriminate himself because he is afraid
that he's going to be forced to testify
that he gave george floyd the drugs that
killed him and then he will be charged
with third-degree manslaughter
that is what he is afraid of or third
degree homicide because he's committing
a felony it's
so that means it's felony murder right
so this is
a serious problem okay if you're the
prosecution normally
it would seem kind of relevant to you
know question the guy in the car floyd
maybe that guy says that floyd wasn't
high maybe that guy says that
floyd wasn't exhibiting no symptoms of
of having any sort of medical trouble
right
all that testimony would be relevant the
prosecution is not offering him immunity
because they don't want him to testify
and the reason they don't want him to
testify is because they are afraid
that then the defense will question the
guy and the defense will say
by the way didn't you give this this guy
enough drugs to kill him
and then the cases exploded so it's kind
of a big deal that maurice hell does not
want to testify
according to nelson eric eric nelson is
the lawyer
for schalvin he says he says
that the jury would hear from hall he
said this will include evidence that
while they were in the car
floyd consumed what he thought were two
percocet painkiller
pills but they were not percocet
nelson said mr floyd's friends will
explain that floyd fell asleep in the
car and that they couldn't wake him to
get him going
and they thought the police might be
coming because the store employees were
coming out
okay but now hall's lawyer says he won't
take the witness stand
the lawyer says your honor i can't
envision any topic mr hall would be
called to testify on that would be both
relevant to the case that would not
incriminate him
mr hall's testimony in these matters
would specifically put him in the
position of being in very close
proximity to mr floyd
in a vehicle where drugs were found
during a search by police following
floyd's death courtney ross
actually testified that maurice hall was
the person selling
pills to floyd right here is here's
courtney ross floyd's girlfriend talking
about this
saying that floyd purchased drugs from
hall in the past these drugs had not
been good for george floyd that they had
exacerbated and made him really agitated
and that they continued to have those
pills around from march through may
would you agree with me that the fbi
agents
asked you from march to may if you
continue to purchase
those pills from the same source
did they ask you that question they did
and you responded
once in a while when we were desperate
agreed that's what it says
yes okay not only that they found
this is an incredible thing okay the the
investigators on the scene
they went to look at the police squad
car okay shelvin's lawyers went to look
at the police squad car this is six
months after the incident okay and what
they turned out to find
were half chewed pills on the floor of
the squad car that had floyd's dna on
them
somehow the police investigators missed
all of that how is that even possible
this is the highest profile criminal
case that we've had in this country
probably since o.j simpson and and the
notion
that they missed key evidence like you
know the half-chewed pills that had meth
and also had fentanyl in them and traces
both in the pills
that those had george floyd's dna on
them in the back of the squad car and
they somehow miss that
facts don't care about your feelings and
it's a fact that the ben shapiro show is
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content